are you having as much fun with near
automata as I am well if you're in
Europe it may be time to dust off that
ps3 of yours now if only you could
remember where the heck you left that
dang thing anyway I met and I don't live
in Europe so this gamespot news update
is a little bit of a bummer Square Enix
Europe has announced that it plans to
reprint the ps3 version of mirror to
celebrate the launch of its spiritual
successor the European branch of the
publishers online store currently has
the ps3 version listed for sale at 25
pounds however at this time you can only
add yourself to a waiting list it's
likely that Square Enix is waiting to
see how much demand there is before
actually reprinting the game will report
back if this offers brought over to
North America so be sure to LIKE and
subscribe to stay up to date on that
near first launched for ps3 and xbox 360
in 2010 at first they received a mixed
critical reception with gamespot's own
review scoring it a 5 out of 10 however
it gained a following and became
somewhat of a cult hit its follow-up
near automata launched last month to
astounding critical acclaim and if you
want to know what we thought of the
bombastic action game then head on over
to our channel and check out our video
review
you